so break you gotta grind grind grind you
got to go through setbacks and
disappointments you got to go through it
so I'm gonna give you a 3-step process
and you can use to break through your
fears break through your discomforts
when you are at your breaking point to
get that little extra push to keep
moving forward we have to have a little
life balance dude how can you have life
balance when you broke
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation that's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message make your
breakthrough over to you Eric Thomas
also if you want to know where Eric and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below even if you're my
closest friend I have boundaries what
I've been telling you to get that gold
get that dream and I'm just been telling
you driving and driving and driving and
driving what I've been talking about is
consistency freshman year in college me
and my boys start like this like
Christian like organizations
[Music]
you want to break or you want
breakthroughs come on I ask you again
you want to break you crowd about you
want to break do you want to break or
break - listen I have lost more loved
ones Miller friend I've gotten so many
calls about people that look I've had so
many setback setbacks I never
experienced I had so many phone calls so
many disappoint like listen to me very
close this has been a challenging year
oh my god
how many more to be said son you wanna
play or you wanna play for us thank God
I can't take them with God it's just so
much bullying God can I take a break he
say you want to break or you want to
break through and I'm asking you
this in order to get a break through
don't break you got a grind grind grind
you got to go through setbacks and
disappointments you got to go through it
so it's not gonna be easy but your boy
ETI said god I'd rather take my
breakthrough gonna take a break so I
need you to get through to get through I
need you to I need you to power through
it
I need you to pray through it I need you
encourage yourself through it I need you
to call your accountability for I need
you do whatever it takes but you better
not quit on me because if you don't take
a break a promise you
your breakthrough is coming if you feel
like you're about to break here's what
you do tell yourself that this is just
the warmup you can't handle another
rejection this is just the warmup you
can't make another call this is just the
warmup
you can't do another set this is just
the warmup
telling yourself when you are at your
breaking point that this is just a
warm-up gives you the mindset shift that
you are capable of more and gives you
the power and belief to keep moving
forward so I look at making these videos
as an example when I shifted my schedule
to do all of my videos on one day I was
worried I was worried that I would hit a
breaking point I was worried that I
wouldn't be capable of doing it and as
soon as that mindset came in as soon as
I had that self-doubt of I'm worried
that I may not be able to do it I'm
worried that I'm hitting my breaking
point that's when that this is just a
warm-up mindset takes over that this
situation right now in front of me
making all these videos in one day I
won't let that be my defining point I
won't let that be bigger than me that
this is just a warm-up because if I am
only capable of this like if this is the
biggest thing in front of me if it's not
possible to do this then it means that
I'm not capable of more it means I can't
handle something bigger whatever problem
you're facing right now that's in front
of you if you feel like it's
overwhelming that it's all-consuming
that it's everywhere that you can't do
anything else but only think about this
and you can't make your way through it
then it means that you're not capable of
doing more I want to believe that I'm
capable of more I want to believe that I
can take on bigger projects I want to
believe that I can handle more
responsibilities than what's currently
on my plate right now because if I can't
if my belief system is I can't go off
and do more then I won't but if you tell
yourself if you shift your mindset that
whenever you're feeling overwhelmed that
this is just a warm-up that I am capable
of doing way more then it gives you a
little bit more of a motivational boost
it gives you some of that self belief to
say I want to do bigger things I am
ready to do bigger things that this big
thing is not that big thing it's just
the warmup
so I'm gonna give you a three-step
process that you can use to break
through your fears break through your
discomforts when you are at your
breaking point to get that little extra
push to keep moving forward step number
one acknowledge when you're close to
breaking acknowledge when you feel like
your energy reserves are getting low not
when you're already past it not when
you're like I'm done I'm I have nothing
left to give I am at the end but when
you're close when you feel yourself
losing energy for the thing or when you
feel the fears creeping in inside your
head that you're worried that you're not
gonna be able to do it you need to catch
yourself while you still have one foot
in the pool you need to catch yourself
while you still have a little bit more
reserves that I am close to reaching my
breaking point step one you have to
acknowledge when you are close to
breaking step two is you need to get to
the truth
here's what happens the human mind is
very interesting and sabotages ourselves
a lot but we like to cover up the truth
you need to get to the truth of why
you're at your breaking point because
what's gonna happen when you are afraid
when you're in close to your breaking
point
you're gonna tell yourself things that
aren't true you're gonna come up with
logical reasons if I'm afraid to make
videos all day long right if I have a
set day I'm gonna make all my videos in
one day I'm gonna come up with logical
reasons why I can't do it I'm gonna tell
myself I won't have enough energy to do
it I'm gonna tell myself it required too
much of my team's effort to do it I'm
gonna come up with all these different
reasons on why I can't do it but the
truth the truth is really just that I'm
afraid that I'm afraid that I may not be
able to pull it off and I don't want to
prove myself right and so you need to
get to the truth you need to get to the
truth of why you are at your breaking
point and not come up with a logical
reason of why you're unwilling to move
forward and then step number three is
you tell yourself this is just a warm-up
I'm capable of more this thing that I am
afraid of this thing that I'm worried
about this thing that is holding me back
this will not define me I am capable of
taking on bigger things this is just the
warmup and say it out loud tell yourself
this is just a warm-up go to the
bathroom look in the mirror this is just
a warm-up you are capable of more I am
capable of more this will not define me
and you'll find that it gives you the
extra strength it gives you the
motivation a boost to move forward so
step one acknowledge when you're close
to
breaking step to get to the truth and
step 3 tell yourself that this is just a
warm-up and you are capable of more now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know where do you need to apply that
this is just a warm-up strategy in your
business or your life let me know put it
in the comments below
you guys to take days off it's my day
off
you need title to a day off
well why do you think you should have
winds diesel for Thursday sir or you
can't work Saturdays or Sunday Sunday
you can't work on a Sunday okay are you
and you got people around you telling
you not to work on son oh we have to
have a little life balance dude how can
you have life balance when you broke how
can you have life balance at a Holiday
Inn when the people next door keep you
up all night and ain't life balance
that's not even a vacation right the
whole trip how many been on the trip you
did the budget trip included the free
breakfast you did it on miles and you
wish you didn't even go how many been on
that trip before maybe you don't do the
trip maybe you're not entitled to a trip
this year maybe you're not ready a trip
that's what Elena and I did for ten
years was sacrifice the sacrifice today
we'll sacrifice this week we'll
sacrifice this month we'll sacrifice
this year we'll sacrifice so one day
maybe we don't have to compromise every
week we talk about our finances what do
we do this week how much do we make
where are we going what are we spending
okay the moment I say hey no more
jackets no more bows stop it she'll stop
it so that we can one day we can one day
spend whatever we want okay there there
there is should come a time where you
guys should be able to spend whatever
you want but most people are spending
what they can't afford now oh and find
out later they can ever have any
understand how to make their money
multiply and most people don't
understand there is a sacrifice phase we
went through the sacrifice phase where
there was years I've just cut off every
and we weren't saving for now you know
because for the rainbow that's right
y'all need to say for the rainbow I mean
you see we didn't go on a vacation for
13 years yeah I've been saving for this
stuff I didn't I wasn't saving for
vacations I was saving so I could bank
into real estate so I could go to sleep
at night and even if I had a bad night
of sleep and had to get up three or four
times I'm like dying I'm making money in
my sleep even if I'm not happy I'm like
I make
money in the sleep man see that's the
goal you and your wife need to have
let's make money when we go to Turks and
Caicos when we go to st. Barts or when
we go to Cali
let's go waste some money later in our
life maybe you say hey I'm gonna
sacrifice today so I don't have to
compromise in the future if you want
more Eric Thomas check out the top fifty
rules video I made on the hem the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there in life when you roll the
dice worst case scenario you're gonna
land on average so don't be average
because if you don't try you will get to
average